Today on DNews, we’re gonna talk about hot
sex.
Greetings people I tricked with the cold open,
Julian here for DNews.
Something odd is happening with central bearded
dragons in Australia.
Suddenly there’s a lot more lady dragons
running around.
And they’re bigger, bolder, and laying more
eggs.
They’re also genetically identical to the
males.
It turns out the sex of bearded dragons isn’t
necessarily determined by their chromosomes.
It can also be determined by the temperature:
if an embryo with a male genetic makeup is
incubated at a certain temperature at a certain
stage of development, it’ll be born a fully
functioning female.
This is actually surprisingly common: the
male to female ratios of many reptiles are
influenced by temperature, including most
turtles and all crocodilians.
Even some fish have temperature dependent
sexual development.
Usually for turtles, eggs incubated at lower
temperatures, say from 22-27 degrees celsius
all become males and eggs incubated at higher
temperatures over 30 degrees celsius all become
females.
If the eggs are incubated at the sweet spot
of 28.5 celsius, the ratio will be 50/50.
Crocodilian species, like the American alligator,
become female if the temperature is low or
high, and the males are spawned at the temperatures
in between.
Species like this don’t have heteromorphic
sex chromosomes like we do, temperature is
everything.
How exactly temperature determines sex remains
a mystery.
It appears to have an impact on aromatase,
an enzyme that converts testosterone to estrogen.
Whether temperature directly affects aromatase,
the gene that makes it, or other proteins
that regulate it remains to be discovered.
But for reptiles like the bearded dragon,
it’s a mix of both the chromosomes they
inherit and the temperature they are incubated
at.
This may sound odd because you’re probably
used to thinking that two X chromosomes makes
a lady and an X and a Y chromosome make a
guy.
Not so for the bearded dragon.
First off instead of X and Y chromosomes they
have what are called Z and W chromosomes.
If an unborn bearded dragon has a Z and a
W chromosome, no matter what the temperature,
it will always be female.
But if it’s homogametic, if it has two Z
chromosomes, then it could be born male or
female.
Of course, male, female, or male-female, they
all still get beards.
Anyway double Z females are on the rise, and
the shift is cause for concern.
If they outcompete the heterogametic females
because they’re more aggressive and lay
more eggs, it’ll cause a massive loss of
genetic diversity after just a couple generations.
Then If temperatures continue to rise it may
lead to all female populations and if that
happens too fast life probably won’t find
a way.
Just like a good party, a balanced male to
female ratio is crucial for the success of
most species.
Basically if you want to be the mother of
dragons, we have to stop climate change.
Man that climate change stuff is the worst.
Mother Nature is one creative lady when it
comes to all the different ways sex can be
expressed.
Like with flat worms and clownfish.
It’s awesome.
Check it out here.
Is saving turtles enough motivation to take
action
on climate change?